[Music]
when I was nine years old I asked my
parents for an allowance since I had
been diligently feeding the cats they
agreed and we settled on three dollars a
week payable on Fridays the first Friday
rolls around and I am so excited we're
sitting at the dinner table and my dad
slowly pulls out a crisp $2 bill and
then a stack of four quarters then he
takes out these two plastic yogurt cups
with Sharpie on them one of them says
family the other one charity dad what's
with the cups my parents calmly
explained to me that out of every
paycheck come certain contributions and
that from my three dollar allowance
twenty-five cents was going to a Family
Tax and twenty-five cents was going to
charity
Oh nine-year-old Alexis with pissed I
done all of the calculations and it was
now going to take literally forever for
me to buy my summer pass the amusement
park so as you can imagine this was my
first taste of the frustrations of
personal finance as we all know this
really pales in comparison to what a lot
of people face on this front people rank
money related concerns as worse than
death and just behind being alone for
the rest of your life and maybe it's no
wonder when we look at it and we find
out that almost half of Americans don't
have four hundred dollars in the case of
an emergency and some people really
can't make this math work
but I know a lot of highly educated
highly motivated people with resources
who still seem to make irrational
decisions about their money I spent the
past seven years working with people who
know a lot about how you and I manage
our finances I was at the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau in DC doing
strategy consulting for big retail banks
and most recently at a consumer FinTech
and even in these environments I came
across people who made irrational
decisions one day I asked my teammate
what about his money habits he's an
expert in helping banks manage risk and
plan for the long term he let me know
all his savings in a checking account
earning zero interest there's got to be
something deeper going on here the
solution I argue is to start from
psychology not from spreadsheets picking
a psychology first approach to personal
finance gives me hope that we can each
learn to better manage our own money and
also change the way that we as a society
talk about personal finance so how can
we make this happen I've come up with
three steps that I'm going to share with
you today so step one understand your
personal financial psychology a few
examples of what this could look like as
Millennials we're investing a lot less
in the stock market than previous
generations and experts say we may have
developed risk aversion from growing up
during the recession people from poorer
households may have a scarcity mindset
which can come from having grown up in
an environment where money is uncertain
and so you end up spending more than you
should be saving
personally I come from a house that kept
spending and personal finance top of
mind as you may have gotten from that
yogurt cup day so this unfortunately can
have its own ramifications and two
weekends ago I was up in San Francisco
and I walked half a mile in five-inch
heels instead of paying five dollars for
parking this is something I'm working on
so where are you coming from and what
does that lead you to do today debt to
implement a system to counteract those
tendencies here at the GSB we talk a lot
about culture building about setting up
incentives for our teams I'm saying we
should do the same for ourselves and
there's a lot of great new innovative
tools out there that can help with us
but they only help when you start from
where you are and build a system around
that so for example if it's risk
aversion you can outsource your
investing activity to a robo advisor who
can take that accountability off of your
plate and make you feel more comfortable
if the issue is a scarcity mindset
instead you can use an app that will
help you with different saving activity
like rounding up your purchases to the
nearest dollar and setting aside that
extra change into a savings account one
thing we can all benefit from it's
finding ways to associate our financial
chores with positive experiences and
with rewards so every month I get a
calendar alert that says adventure fund
and there's just a bunch of exclamation
points over here and like maybe a few
emojis and this is my alert to move my
extra cash for my checking account into
a high interest savings account so I can
earn a few extra points of interest on
money that would be sitting around
anyway by finding a way to take this
financial chore and associate it with
something I love with travel with the
feelings I'm going to
now when I actually get to use that
savings I get to move that future
feeling of reward to the present this
sims are the ways that we can actually
build habits
it's the ways that we can end up
sticking to our goals and through
automation and association with positive
feelings and rewards we can actually end
up changing our behaviors which leads me
to step 3 you have this system now what
share it a whopping 43% of Americans
don't know how much money their spouse
makes think about that how are we
supposed to plan for shared futures when
we don't have this information how are
our loved ones supposed to hold us
accountable to our goals how can we help
the people we care about in our lives
we're taking classes right now on
accounting and finance we're making
these huge decisions about taking on
debt about what career we're gonna have
what implication that's gonna have for
our salaries and yet none of us are
talking about money even if you're in a
good place with us I guarantee you
someone close to you is sitting here
with a really bad hit in their stomach
and we all have a responsibility to
change the ways that we talk about money
to take away the shame from that
conversation so if you've recently gone
through a salary negotiation you can
help someone else get a raise if you've
got a great system for your savings you
can help someone else get over that
hurdle if you just start talking about
money you can welcome someone else who
needs help to do the same
tackling these three steps understand
your personal financial psychology
implement a system to counteract those
tendencies and share it will empower
each of us to live better financial
lives and change the ways that we as a
society approach money I care way too
much about my friends and family to let
them struggle unnecessarily with their
finances
you can bet someday I'm gonna tax my own
kids allowance and by that point it'll
probably be more like a dollar instead
of 25 cents they'll pay it forward with
a little less than about inflation
[Applause]
[Music]